al momento no había un pronunciamiento
formal por parte de la administración de
nicolás maduro luego que se conociera
este fallo de la juez de la división
comercial de tribunal supremo de londres
a favor de la junta
que fue designada por juan guaidó con
respecto al banco central de venezuela
recordemos que reinó unido- reconoce a
juan oído como presidente interino de
venezuela en este litigio que se lleva a
cabo por las reservas de oro que se
encuentran actualmente en el banco de
inglaterra sin embargo se conoció que la
administración de nicolás maduró
apelaría esta decisión si goya
reacciones por parte del dirigente juan
guaidó a través de un comunicado celebró
esta decisión y dijo que se trataba de
un paso más en el proceso de protección
de las reservas internacionales de
venezuela estaríamos hablando de 31
toneladas de oro que se encuentran en el
banco de inglaterra estás valoradas en
más de mil millones de dólares